en 1873 tout jeune marié annette poulard
prenait le bail de l'auberge saint
michel tête d'or au mont saint michel
mais en ce temps là comme les touristes
ne pouvait venir qu'à marée basse il
était très difficile d'avoir des plats
toujours prêt c'est pourquoi madame
poulard pensa à faire des omelettes
voici sa recette je casse de bronze par
personne dans une terrine que l'eba bien
[Musique]
puis je mets d'un morceau de très bon
beurre légèrement salée dans la poêle
[Musique]
j'y jette les deux battus je fais cuire
sur un bon feu de bois de chêne
je retire de temps en temps de la flamme
pour laisser souffler je détache bien
les bords
[Musique]
puis je plie dans un plat comme un
chausson et je sers bien chaud ainsi
disette et faisait la mère poulard qui
lie à bientôt 100 ans
maintenant on pourrait faire comme elle
et régalez vos amis
[Musique]